Ce matin, Vassil va dégager la tombe
qu'il vient de découvrir à une dizaine
de mètres sous la surface du désert.
Sous ses ordres, une cinquantaine d'ouvriers
s'activent autour du puits funéraire,
mais personne n'est autorisé à pénétrer
dans le tombeau avant l'archéologue.
- Il faut faire le moins possible
de vibrations.
Parce que, à l'intérieur, il y a un linteau
sur lequel il y a pas mal de sable.
Donc il ne faut pas que ça se casse.
Voilà la structure de la tombe
que Vassil la mise au jour.
Un puits vertical de 10 mètres de profondeur,
qui conduit au caveau,
fait de blocs de calcaire décorés.
À l'intérieur, l'archéologue espère découvrir
un sarcophage et peut-être une momie,
et des objets funéraires.
Mais avant cela, il va falloir vider la tombe
qui est entièrement remplie de gravats.
Impossible pour l'instant de savoir
ce qui se trouve toujours en dessous.
Bientôt le haut des murs apparaît.
Malgré le sable, les couleurs sont intactes
et les premières inscriptions livrent
rapidement de précieuses indications.
- Ici, on commence à voir une formule,
c'est la formule d'offrande.
C'est le roi qui offre une offrande
pour le dieu Anubis,
qui est le dieu de la momification.
Et c'est au bout seulement de cette ligne,
qu'on va peut-être avoir le nom et les titres
du personnage qui est enterré ici.
Voilà, il y a d'autres offrandes qui
apparaissent là.
Ça, ce sont les pots et les jarres,
dans lesquels on mettait les huiles.
Sans ces huiles, on ne ressuscite pas.
Ça, c'est clair.
Dans la civilisation égyptienne,
ce qui est représenté sur les murs
possède un pouvoir magique.
Ces cuisses de bœuf, par exemple, permettent
au défunt de s'alimenter dans l'au-delà.
- Quand on mange de la viande, on est fort.
Et, on voudrait dans l'autre vie être fort.
Même aujourd'hui,
les gens le disent en arabe.
Quand on voit quelqu'un de fort,
on ne dit pas "il est très fort".
On dit "il mange de la viande".
Vassil pense que ces peintures
ont environ 4200 ans,
elles sont pourtant dans un état
de conservation remarquable.
On peut même voir les maladresses
du peintre qui les a réalisées.
L'archéologue peut à présent
se glisser au fond de la tombe.
Il va tenter d'y repérer les hiéroglyphes
qui indiquent le nom et la fonction
de la personne qui a été enterrée ici.
- Maintenant, on voit l'inscription :
"Très lecteur, scribe magicien".
Je crois qu'il s'appelle Sabi.
Oui, il s'appelle Sabi.
- Ce qui veut dire ?
- En gros, ma protection.
Ou quelque chose comme ça.
Ce personnage vient de ressusciter,
dans l'histoire,
parce qu'on vient de prononcer son nom.
C'est exactement ce qu'ils cherchaient.
Pour eux, c'était ça la résurrection,
Ça la vie après la mort.
Imaginez l'importance que c'est.
Est-ce que quelqu'un va prononcer notre nom
en 6000 après notre ère ?
Comme on est aujourd'hui, 6000 ans après.
Donc, personne ne pensera à mon nom,
ni votre nom,
ni celui du président de la République.
On ne connaîtra même pas.
Alors que nous, on vient de prononcer
le nom d'un simple prêtre,
qui s'est fait enterrer ici.
Et donc lui, en revanche, il existe.
Des gravats se sont accumulés
sur ce qui reste du plafond.
Il faut les retirer
pour éviter l'effondrement.
Dans les déblais,
une surprise attend l'archéologue.
- Enlève le sable au-dessus.
Des objets apparaissent,
un petit couvercle en pierre peinte
et une trouvaille
encore plus exceptionnelle.
- Je crois que c'est une statuette
en bois.
C'est plutôt rare des objets comme ça.
Parce que pour que ça se préserve
depuis des millénaires,
il faut un bon endroit, bien fermé.
Autrement, le bois pourri.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'elle fait là ?
Elle devrait être en bas.
- Elle est sur le plafond !
- Quelqu'un l'a pris,
et l'a jetée derrière, sur le plafond.
Ça, il faut la placer.
La tombe a donc été pillée dans l'antiquité.
Mais coup de chance,
les voleurs ont abandonné plusieurs objets.
C'est un petit pot en calcaire.
Une pièce toute simple dont la valeur se
compte pourtant en milliers d'euros.
Tous ces objets étaient censés
aider le défunt à revivre après la mort.
- Ce sont des vases simulacre, c'est-à-dire,
qu'ils ont juste une fonction factice,
mais ils représentent
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 jarres.
Là, c'est beaucoup plus petit,
mais imaginons, que ce sont des jarres
avec de la bière, avec des liquides,
avec des huiles, avec des choses comme ça.
Quant à la statue, elle représente
sans doute le propriétaire de la tombe.
Mais le haut du corps n'a pas résisté.
- Malheureusement, elle est toute pourrie.
On ne peut pas la bouger.
Si on la bouge, elle part en poussière.
Vous voyez, la tête n'existe plus.
Le bas du corps est parfait,
mais la tête n'existe plus.
Peu importe que la statuette
ne soit pas entière,
il faut sauver ce qui peut encore l'être.
Ali, le restaurateur de la mission,
est appelé pour préserver
ce petit bout de bois sculpté
il y a plus de 4000 ans.
- C'est un produit à base de cellulose.
C'est pour le bois, pour consolider le bois.
Soit, elle a pourri avec le temps,
parce qu'elle était dans le sable,
et ne s'est pas bien conservée.
Soit les voleurs qui sont passés par ici
exactement l'ont peut-être décapités,
ils ont enlevé les yeux, parce qu'ils
ne voulaient pas se faire reconnaître.
Ils avaient peur,
quand ils veulent quelque chose,
que le propriétaire de la tombe,
qui va ressusciter,
qui a déjà peut-être ressuscité,
qui le voit, et qui le dénonce,
qu'il dénonce à Osiris.
Comme ça, ce voleur, lui qui espère
aussi ressusciter un jour
ou espère aussi passer un bon ou
quelqu'un de très bien.
Comme ça, notre Sabi va lui dire
"Mais non, celui-là a volé ma tombe.
Donc celui-là, il ne peut pas ressusciter."
La statue, même très abîmée,
est une indication des objets
qui se trouvaient dans la tombe
au moment de l'enterrement.
Pour l'archéologue, c'est donc un témoignage
très précieux.
Dernière étape, Vassil et ses ouvriers,
vident le reste de la tombe.
Ils ont encore l'espoir de trouver
les vestiges du prêtre Sabi,
Peut-être des restes de sa momie,
ou de son sarcophage.
Mais malheureusement,
rien n'a échappé aux pilleurs.
- Donc là, les choses sont claires.
Ça a été entièrement violé.
Car on trouve le crâne,
sous la pierre fracassée.
Tu as vu dans quel état il est ?
- Ça vous rend triste ?
- Oui, c'est surtout pour Sabi.
Voilà ce qui reste de lui.
Bien que la tombe ait été pillée,
les trouvailles d'aujourd'hui
sont exceptionnelles.
Ce caveau entièrement peint
va rejoindre le tableau de chasse
de Vassil sur le plateau de Saqqara.